the Joe Rogan experience what happens
when you become president and what do
you think happens and why do these do
you think that there are full of [ __ ]
and they're just saying what what we
want to hear so they can get elected or
do you think that there is something
that happens to them once they get into
office do you think that it's possible
that they're given information that
shows the the real threats that the
world has and there's things that the
general public is just not privy to and
these are what influences people's
decisions to go against all the things
that they were saying when they're
running for president yeah look I
haven't been with them and I've been in
those rooms so I won't speak for for
that which I do not know but what I do
know is this is what happens when you
have people who are elected to serve in
this job as president whose most
important responsibilities as
commander-in-chief and they lack the
experience and the understanding to be
able to make the right kinds of
decisions that serve the American people
and end up even those going in with the
best of intentions end up being very
influenced whether it be by the
military-industrial complex or the
foreign policy establishment that as
we've seen over decades has crossed both
political parties both political parties
in these areas often end up making the
very same decisions about continuing
these wasteful regime change wars and
acting as the world's police and
therefore listening to them because they
lack that experience or that backbone
and understanding themselves and then
just continue the status quo
you know Trump was somebody who during
his campaign talked a lot about ending
the stupid Wars talked about going after
Saudi Arabia that they're the biggest
supporters of terrorism in the world and
you know what happened now you know in
his administration what
he called draining the swamp he's turned
that swamp into a cesspool you look at
the people he's surrounded himself by
some of the biggest war Hawks that our
country has seen guys like John Bolton
people like Mike Pompeo people who've
wanted to go to war against Iran for a
very long time people who have been cozy
with Saudi Arabia for a very long time
you see who he's nominating to be
Secretary of Defense longtime defense
contract career man like over 30 years I
think working for Boeing you see the
kinds of people who he surrounded
himself by and so it's it it doesn't
take a lot to figure out how he has been
influenced by them in continuing these
regime change or this regime change is
still going on in Syria now threatening
regime change in Venezuela threatening
regime change in disruption in Iran and
that's the difference that's the
difference quite bluntly between me and
other people who are running for
president is that experience and
understanding that I bring to be able to
walk into that office to do that job as
commander-in-chief and on day one and to
not succumb to the the establishment
that that I have both felt the effects
of as a soldier as well as seen in
action as a member of Congress I'm going
in with both both eyes wide open and
understanding the situation as it really
exists and most importantly
understanding who I work for that I work
for the American people do you think
when someone like Trump radically shifts
his position he's doing so because it's
been influenced to change his position
because he's been given more information
or do you think they become compromised
when they're on in office and they I
scratch your back you scratch mine uh I
don't know I imagine that there's
probably some of both mm but if you're
if you don't have the strength of your
convictions and your understanding about
what kinds of policies actually best
serve the American people then you can
see how easily you'd be swayed and
influenced by others you know you saw
Trump's rhetoric on the campaign trail
about Saudi Arabia against Saudi Arabia
against the United States support for
Saudi Arabia calling them out for what
they are
and now refusing to end US military
support for this genocide 'el war in
Yemen that Saudi Arabia is waging that's
created the worst humanitarian crisis of
our generation because he says well he
doesn't want to risk a
multibillion-dollar arms deal with Saudi
Arabia
so you know you can see at least in that
respect what he's really motivated by
that he doesn't he would rather continue
to support the senseless and devastating
deaths of innocent people in Yemen and
using our US military my brothers and
sisters in the military to do that
because he doesn't want to risk an arms
deal with Saudi Arabia theocratic
dictatorship that actually directly
supports terrorist groups like Al Qaeda
it's hard for people to imagine that
that's the case that it's an arms deal
and they want to make sure that this
deal goes through and that it continues
to be financially productive for both
nations well that's you know this is
Trump's argument he's like well you know
that's American jobs building those
weapons that we're selling to Saudi
Arabia that's what's at risk my
challenge to him and to the American
people is if the best our president can
do to help support the creation of jobs
in this country is to build weapons that
are being dropped on innocent people in
countries like Yemen then we need a new
president
we need a new commander-in-chief it will
actually help serve the best interests
of our people and work towards the
interests of peace peace here at home
and peace abroad yeah the idea that it's
just jobs it's not just jobs I mean
there's consequences to these jobs